LUCASZ KAISER: Hi, my
name is Lucasz Kaiser,
and I want to tell you
in this final session
about Tensor2Tensor,
which is a library we've
built on top of TensorFlow to
organize the world's models
and data sets.
So I want to tell you
about the motivation,
and how it came together,
and what you can do with it.
But also if you
have any questions
in the meantime
anytime, just ask.
And only if you've already used
Tensor2Tensor, in that case,
you might have even
more questions.
But the motivation
behind this library
is-- so I am a researcher
in machine learning.
I also worked from production
[INAUDIBLE] models,
and research can
be very annoying.
It can be very annoying
to researchers,
and it's even more
annoying to people
who put it into production,
because the research works
like this.
You have an idea.
You want to try it out.
It's machine learning,
and you think,
well, I will change something
in the model, it will be great.
It will solve physics problems,
or translation, or whatever.
So we have this idea, and
you're like, it's so simple.
I just need to change one
tweak, but then, OK, I
need to get the data.
Where was it?
So we search it
online, you find it,
and it's like, well, so
I need to preprocess it.
You implement some data reading.
You download the model
that someone else did.
And it doesn't give
the result at all
that someone else
wrote in the paper.
It's worse.
It works 10 times slower.
It doesn't train at all.
So then you start tweaking it.
Turns out, someone else
had this postscript
that preprocessed the
data in a certain way that
improved the model 10 times.
So you add that.
Then it turns out your input
pipeline is not performing,
because it doesn't put data
on GPU or CPU or whatever.
So you tweak that.
Before you start with
your research idea,
you've spent half a
year on just reproducing
what's been done before.
So then great.
Then you do your idea.
It works.
You write the paper.
You submit it.
You put it in the
repo on GitHub,
which has a README
file that says,
well, I downloaded
the data from there,
but this link has
already gone by two days
after he made the repo.
And then I applied.
And you describe
all these 17 tweaks,
but maybe you forgot one
option that was crucial.
Well, and then there is the next
paper and the next research,
and the next person
comes and does the same.
So it's all great except the
production team, at some point,
they get like, well, we
should put it into production.
It's a great result.
And then they
need to track this whole
path, redo all of it,
and try to get the same.
So it's a very difficult
state of the world.
And it's even worse because
there are different hardware
configurations.
So maybe something that
trained well on a CPU
does not train on a GPU, or
maybe you need an 8 GPU setup,
and so on and so forth.
So the idea behind
Tensor2Tensor was,
let's make a library
that has at least a bunch
of standard models for
standard tasks that includes
the data and the preprocessing.
So you really can, on a
command line, just say,
please get me this data set
and this model, and train it,
and make it so that we can have
regression tests and actually
know that it will train, and
that it will not break with
TensorFlow 1.10.
And that it will train both
on the GPU and on a TPU,
and on a CPU--
to have it in a more
organized fashion.
And the thing that
prompted Tensor2Tensor,
the thing why I started it,
was machine translation.
So I worked with the
Google Translate team
on launching neural
networks for translation.
And this was two years ago,
and this was amazing work.
Because before that,
machine translation
was done in this way like--
it was called phrase-based
machine translation.
So if you find some
alignments of phrases,
then you translate the
phrases, and then you
try to realign the
sentences to make them work.
And the results in
machine translation
are normally measured
in terms of something
called the BLEU score.
I will not go into the
details of what it was.
It's like the higher the better.
So for example, for
English-German translation,
the BLEU score that human
translators get is about 30.
And the best phrase-based--
so non-neural network,
non-deep-learning--
systems were about 20, 21.
And it's been, really, a
decade of research at least,
maybe more.
So when I was doing a PhD,
if you got one BLEU score up,
you would be a star.
It was good PhD.
If you went from 21 to
22, it would be amazing.
So then the neural
networks came.
And the early LSTMs in 2015,
they were like 19.5, 20.
And we talked to
the Translate team,
and they were like, you
know, guys, it's fun.
It's interesting, because
it's simpler in a way.
You just train the
network on the data.
You don't have all the--
no language-specific stuff.
It's a simpler system.
But it gets worse
results, and who knows
if it will ever get better.
But then the neural
network research moved on,
and people started
getting 21, 22.
So the Translate team, together
with Brain, where I work,
made the big effort to try
to make a really large LSTM
model, which is called the
GNMT, the Google Neural Machine
Translation.
And indeed it was
a huge improvement.
It got to 25.
BLEU, later-- we added mixtures
of experts, it even got to 26.
So they were amazed.
It launched in
production, and well, it
was like a two-year
effort to take the papers,
scale them up, launch it.
And to get these
really good results,
you really needed
a large network.
So as an example why
this is important,
or why this was
important for Google is--
so you have a sentence
in German here,
which is like,
"problems can never
be solved with the same way
of thinking that caused them."
And this neural translator
translates the sentence kind
of the way it should--
I doubt there is a much
better translation--
while the phrase-based
translators, you can see,
"no problem can be solved
from the same consciousness
that they have arisen."
It kind of shows how the
phrase-based method works.
Every word or phrase is
translated correctly,
but the whole thing
does not exactly add up.
You can see it's a
very machiney way,
and it's not so clear what
it is supposed to say.
So the big advantage
of neural networks
is they train on
whole sentences.
They can even train
on paragraphs.
They can be very fluent.
Since they take into account
the whole context at once,
it's a really big improvement.
And if you ask people
to score translations,
this really starts
coming close--
or at least 80% of the distance
to what human translators do,
at least on newspaper
language-- not poetry.
[CHUCKLING]
We're nowhere near that.
So it was great.
We got the high BLEU scores.
We reduced the distance
to human translators.
It turned out the
one system can handle
different languages,
and sometimes even
multilingual translations.
But there were problems.
So one problem is
the training time.
It took about a week on a
setup of 64 to 128 GPUs.
And all the code for that
was done specifically
for this hardware setup.
So it was distributed
training where
everything in the
machine learning pipeline
was tuned for the hardware.
Well, because we knew we
will train on this data
center on this hardware.
So why not?
Well, the problem is batch
sizes and learning rates,
they come together.
You can not tune
them separately.
And then you add tricks.
Then you tweak some
things in the model
that are really good
for this specific setup,
for this specific learning
grade or batch size.
This distributed setup was
training asynchronously.
So there were delayed gradients.
It's a regular [? ISO, ?]
so you decrease dropout.
You start doing
parts of the model
specifically for
a hardware setup.
And then you write the paper.
We did write a paper.
It was cited.
But nobody ever
outside of Google
managed to reproduce
this, get the same result
with the same network,
because we can give you
our hyperparameters, but you're
running on a different hardware
setup.
You will not get
the same result.
And then, in addition to
the machine learning setup,
there is the whole will
tokenization pipeline, data
preparation pipeline.
And even though these results
are on the public data,
the whole pre-processing
is also partially Google.
It doesn't matter much.
But it really did not
allow other people
to build on top of this work.
So it launched, it
was a success for us,
but in the research
sense, we felt that it
came short a little bit.
Because for one, I mean, you'd
need a huge hardware setup
to train it.
And on the other hand, even
if you had the hardware setup,
or if you got it on cloud
and wanted to invest in it,
there would still be no
way for you to just do it.
And that was the
prompt, why I thought,
OK, we need to make a
library for the next time
we build a model.
So the LSTMs were like the
first wave of sequence models
with the first great results.
But I thought, OK, the next
time when we come build a model,
we need to have a library that
will ensure it works at Google
and outside, that will make
sure when you train on one GPU,
you get a worse result,
but we know what it is.
We can tell you, yes,
you're on the same setup.
Just scale up.
And it should work on
cloud so you can just,
if you want better
result, get some money,
pay for larger hardware.
But it should be tested, done,
and reproducible outside.
And the need-- so the
Tensor2Tensor library started
with the model
called Transformer,
which is the next generation
of sequence models.
It's based on
self-attentional layers.
And we designed this model.
It got even better results.
It got 28.4 BLEU.
Now we are on par with BLEU
with human translators.
So this metric is
not good anymore.
It just means that we
need better metrics.
But this thing, it can train
in one day on an 8 GPU machine.
So you can just get it.
Get an 8 GPU machine.
It can be your machine,
it can be in the cloud.
Train, get the results.
And it's not just
reproducible in principle.
There's been a number of
groups that reproduced it, got
the same results,
wrote follow-up papers,
changed the architecture.
It went up to 29,
it went up to 30.
There are companies
that use this code.
They launched competition
to Google Translate.
Well, that happens.
And Google Translate
improved again.
But in a sense, I feel like it's
been a larger success in terms
of community and research, and
it raised the bar for everyone.
It raised our quality as well.
So that's how it
came to be that we
feel that it's really important
to make things reproducible,
open, and test them on
different configurations
and different hardwares.
Because then we can isolate
what parts are really
good fundamentally from
the parts that are just
tweaks that work in
one configuration
and fail in the other.
So that's our solution to this
annoying research problem.
It's a solution that
requires a lot of work,
and it's based on many layers.
So the bottom layer
is TensorFlow.
And TensorFlow, in the meantime,
has also evolved a lot.
So we have TF Data, which is the
TensorFlow data input pipeline.
It was also not
there a year ago.
It's in the newer releases.
It helps to build
input pipelines that
are performant across
different hardware.
There is TF Layers
and Keras, which
are higher-level libraries.
So you don't need to
write, in small TensorFlow
Ops, everything.
You can write things on a
higher level of abstraction.
There is the new
distribution strategy,
which allows you to
have an estimator
and say, OK, train
on eight GPUs,
train on one GPU, train
on a distributed setup,
train on TPU.
You don't need rewrite handlers
for everything on your own.
But that's just the basics.
And then comes the Tensor2Tensor
part, which is like, OK,
I want a good translation model,
where do I get the data from?
It's somewhere on the
internet, but where?
How do I download it?
How do I pre-process it?
Which model should I use?
Which hyperparameters
of the model?
What if I want to
change a model?
I just want to try my
own, but on the same data.
What do I need to change?
How can it be done?
What if I want to use the same
model, but on my own data?
I have a translation company.
I have some data.
I want to check how that works.
What if I want to share?
What if I want to share a part?
What if I want to
share everything?
That's what Tensor2Tensor does.
So it's a library.
It's a library that has
a lot of data sets--
I think it's more
than 100 by now--
all the standard ones, images,
ImageNet, CIFAR, MNIST,
image captionings,
Coco, translations
for a number of languages,
just pure language
modeling data sets, speech to
text, music, video data sets.
It's recently very active.
If you're into research, you
can either probably find it here
or there is a very easy
tutorial on how to add it.
And then with the data
sets come the models.
There is the transformer,
as I said you--
told you-- that's
how it started.
But then the standard things,
ResNet, then more fancy image
models like RevNet, ShakeShake,
Xception, Sequence Model,
also a bunch of them,
SliceNet, ByteNet,
that's subversion of WaveNet.
LSTMs then algorithmic
models like Neural GPUs.
There was a bunch
of recent papers.
So it's a selection of
models and data sets,
but also the framework.
So if you want to train a model,
there is one way to do it.
There are many models.
You need to specify which one.
And there are many datasets.
But there is one
training binary.
So it's always the same.
No two page read me,
please run these commands
and for another run
different comments.
Same for decoding.
You want to get your the
outputs of your model
on the new data set?
One command, t2t decoder.
You want to export it to
make a server or a website?
One command.
And then you want to
train, train locally,
you just run the binary.
If you want to train
on Google Cloud,
just give your cloud project ID.
You want to train on cloud
TPU, just say dash dash use TPU
and give the ID.
You need to tune
hyper parameters.
There is support for
it on Google Cloud.
We have ranges.
Just specify the
hyperparameter range and tune.
You want to train distributed
on multiple machines,
there is a script for that.
So Tensor2Tensor are data
sets, models, and everything
around that's needed
to train them.
Now, this project, due to our
experience with translation,
we decided it's open
by default. And open
by default, in a similar
way as TensorFlow,
means every internal
code change we push gets
immediately pushed to GitHub.
And every PR from GitHub, we
import internally and merge.
So there is just one code base.
And since this project is
pure Python, there's no magic.
It's the same code at
Google and outside.
And it's like internally we have
dozens of code changes a day.
They get pushed out
to GitHub immediately.
And since a lot of brain
researchers use this daily,
there are things like this.
So there was a tweet about
research and optimizers.
And it was like, there
are optimizers like AMS
grad, adaptive learning
create methods.
And then James
Bradbury at Facebook
at that time tweeted, well,
it's not the latest optimizer.
The latest optimizer is in
Tensor2Tensor encode with a
to do to write a paper.
The paper is written now.
It's a very good optimizer
[INAUDIBLE] factor.
But yeah, the code,
it just appears there.
The papers come later.
But it makes no sense to wait.
I mean, it's an open
research community.
These ideas, sometimes they
work, sometimes they don't.
But that's how we work.
We push things out.
And then we train and see.
Actually, by the time
the paper appeared,
some people in the
open source community
have already trained
models with it.
So we added the results.
They were happy to.
It's a very good optimizer,
saves a lot of memory.
It's a big collaboration.
So as I said, this is
just one list of names.
It should probably
be longer by now.
It's a collaboration between
Google Brain, DeepMind.
Currently there are researchers
from the Czech Republic
on GitHub and Germany, so
over 100 contributors by now,
over 100,000 downloads.
I was surprised, because Ryan
got this number for this talk.
And I was like, how comes
there are 100,000 people using
this thing?
It's for ML researchers.
But whatever, they are.
And there are a lot
of papers that use it.
So these are just the
papers that have already
been published and accepted.
There is a long
pipeline of other papers
and possibly some
we don't know about.
So as I told you, it's a
unified framework for models.
So how does it work?
Well, the main script of the
whole library is t2t-trainer.
It's the one binary where you
tell what model, what data set,
what hyperparameters, go train.
So that's the basic command
line-- install tensor2tensor
and then call t2t-trainer.
The problem is the
name of the dataset.
And it also includes
all details like how
to pre-process, how to resize
images, and so on and so forth.
Model is the name of the
model and hyperparameter set
is which configuration,
which hyperparameters
of the model, which learning
grades, and so on, to use.
And then, of course,
you need to specify
where to store the
data, where to store
the model checkpoints for how
many steps to train and so on.
But that's the full command.
And for example, you want
a summarization model.
There is a
summarization data set
that's been used in academia.
It's from CNN and Daily Mail.
You say you want
the transformer,
and there is a
hyperparameter set that
does well on summarization.
You want to image
classification,
like CIFAR10 is quite a
standard benchmark for papers.
You say, I want image CIFAR10.
ShakeShake model, this was
state of the art a year
or a year ago.
This changes quickly.
You want the big
model, you go train it.
And the important thing
is we know this result.
This gives less than 3% error
on CIFAR, which is, as I said,
was state of the art a year ago.
Now it's down to two.
But we can be
certain that when you
run this command for the
specified number of training
steps, you will actually
get this state of the art,
because internally we
run regression tests that
start this every day
and tell us if it fails.
So the usefulness of this
framework is not just in--
well, we have it grouped
into one command.
But because it's automated,
we can start testing it.
If there is a new change
in TensorFlow that
will break some kernel
and it doesn't come out
in the unit test,
it often comes out
in the regression
tests of these models.
And we found at least three
bugs in the recent two versions
of TensorFlow, because some
things in machine learning only
appear--
like, things still run,
things still train,
but they give you 2% less.
These are very
tricky bugs to find,
but if you know which
day it started failing,
it's much easier.
Translation, as I said, it
started with transformer.
We added more changes.
Nowadays, it trains
to over 29 BLEU.
It's a very good
translation model.
Just run this command
on an 8 GPU machine.
Wait.
You will get a really
good translator.
Speech recognition, there is
the open librispeech data set.
Transformer model without
any language model
gets a really good
word error rate.
Some more fancy things, like
if you want to generate images,
it's recently popular, have a
model that just generates you.
Either phases or landscapes,
there are different datasets.
So this is a model
that you train just
on CIFAR 10 reversed.
Every data set in
tensor2tensor you
can add this underscore rev.
It reverses inputs and targets.
And generative models, they
can take it and generate it.
For translation,
it's very useful
if you want, instead of English,
German, and German, English,
you just do underscore
rev. It reverses
the ordering of the dataset.
So yeah, so they're
the commands.
But so for example, on
an image transformer,
if you try to train
this on a single GPU
to get to this 2.9
beats per dimension,
you'd probably have
to wait half a year.
So that's not very practical.
But that's the point.
Currently it's a very hard
task to do a very good image
generative model.
One GPU might not be enough
for state of the art.
So if you want to really push
it, you need to train at scale.
You need to train multi GPU.
You need to go to TPUs.
Well, this is the command
you've seen before.
To make it multi GPU, you
just say worker GPU equals 8.
This will use eight
GPUs on your machine.
Just make batches
eight times larger.
Run the eight GPUs in
parallel, and there it trains.
Want to train on a cloud TPU?
Use TPU, and you need to specify
the master of the TPU instance
that you booked on cloud.
It trains the same.
Want to train on
a cloud TPU pod?
I don't know, I guess
you've heard today,
Google is opening up to public
the pods which go up to 256,
I think, TPU cores.
Just say, oh, maybe up to 512,
what I see from this command.
Just say do it.
Train.
It will train much faster.
How much faster?
Well, we've observed
nearly linear scaling up
to half a pod, and I think,
like, 10% loss on a full pod.
So these models, the
translation models,
they can train on
a pod for an hour,
and you get state of
the art performance.
So this can really make
you train very fast.
Same for ImageNet.
Well, I say an hour,
there's now a competition.
Can we get down to half
an hour, 18 minutes.
I'm not sure how important
that is, but it's really fast.
Now, maybe you don't
just care about training
one set of hyperparameters.
Maybe you have your
own data set and you
need to tune hyperparameters,
find a really good model
for your application.
Say cloud ML engine auto tune.
You need to say what
metric to optimize--
so accuracy, perplexity,
these are the standard metrics
that people tune the models for.
Say how many trials, how many
of them to run in parallel.
And the final line is a range.
So a range says, well,
try learning grades
from 0.1 to 0.3,
logarithmically or uniformly.
These are the
things you specify.
So you can specify continuous
things in an interval
and you can specify
discrete things.
Just try two, three,
four, five layers.
And the tuner, it starts the
number of parallel trials,
so 20 in this command.
The first one is random,
and then the next one,
it has a quite sophisticated
non-differential optimizing
model which is Bayesian
mixed with CMAES.
What to try next, it will
try another 20 trials.
Usually after, like, 60
or so it starts getting
to a good parameter space.
So if you need to optimize,
that's how you do it.
And, like, if you're wondering
what range to optimize,
we have a few ranges
in code that we usually
optimize for when we
start with new data.
On a TPU pod, if you want
a model that doesn't just
do training on
large batches, data
parallel, but model parallel.
If you want to have a model with
a huge number of parameters,
more than one
billion, you can use
something we call mesh
TensorFlow that we also
have started developing
in tensor2tensor,
which allows to do model
parallelism in an easy way.
It just say, split my
tensor into the cores,
how many cores you have.
Or split it eight-wise on
this dimension and four-wise
on this dimension.
I'll tell a bit more
later about that.
It allows you to train really
large models if you want this.
And that gives
really good results.
So that's how the library works.
You can go and use it
with the models and data
sets that are there.
But what if you want to just
get the data from the data set
or to add your own data set?
Well, it's still
a Python library.
You can just import it.
And there is this
problem class, which
you can use without any
other part of the library.
So you can just--
you get an instance
of the problem class
either by-- so we
have this registry
to call things by name.
So you can say registry
dot problem and the name.
You can say problems
dot available to get
all the available names.
Or you can instantiate
it directly.
If you look into the code where
the class is, you can say,
give me this class.
And then generate data.
The problem class knows where
on the internet to find the data
and how to pre-process it.
So the generate data
will go to this place,
download it from the internet,
and pre-process into TF example
files in the same
way that we use it
or that the authors
of this data set
decide it is good
for their models.
And then you call a problem
dot data set, which reads it
from this, can gives you
this queue of tensors
in the form of a data set.
So that's for data sets.
For a model, all our
models are a subclass
of this t2t model class,
which itself is a Keras layer.
So if you want to
take one model,
plug it together with another
one, same as with layers.
You get a model.
You can get it again either
by registry or by class name.
Call the model on a
dictionary of tensors.
And you get the outputs
and the losses if you need.
So you can add your own.
You can subclass the
base problem class,
or for text to text or
image to class problems,
there are subclasses that
are easier to subclass.
You just basically point where
your images are and get them
from any format to this.
And for your own model,
you can subclass t2t model.
If you want to share
it, it's on GitHub.
Make a PR.
Under models, there is
a research sub directory
where there are models
that we don't consider,
that we don't regression test.
We allow them to be free.
If you have an idea, want
to share, put it there.
People might come, run
it, tell you it's great.
So yeah, Tensor2Tensor,
it's a set of data sets,
models, and scripts
to run it everywhere.
And yeah, looking
ahead, it's growing.
So we are happy to
have more data sets.
We are happy to
have more models.
We are ramping up on
regression testing.
We're moving models
out of research
to the more official
part to have them
tested and stabilized.
On the technical side,
we are on to simplifying
the infrastructure.
So TensorFlow 2 is coming.
The code base-- well, it's
started more than a year ago.
It's based on estimators.
We are moving it to Keras.
We had our own
scripts and binaries
for running on
TPUs and multi-GPUs
or moving to a
distribution strategy.
We are allowing
experts to TF hub.
So this is a library for
training your own models.
The main thing is the trainer.
Once it's trained and you want
to share a pre-trained model,
TF hub is the right place.
You can export it with one line.
And the mesh TensorFlow
allows to train huge models
on cloud pods.
I will tell you a little bit
more about it in a moment.
On the research side, there's
been a lot of research
in video models recently.
We have a ton of them
in Tensor2Tensor.
And they're getting
better and better.
And it's a fun thing to
generate your own videos.
There is-- the new thing
in machine translation
is using back translation.
So it uses an unsupervised--
you have a corpus of English
and a corpus of German,
but no matching.
And to use a model you have
to generate data and then back
translate and it
shows improvements.
And in general, well,
hyperparameter tuning
is an important thing
in research, too.
So it's integrated
now, and we're
doing more and more of it.
Reinforcement learning,
guns, well, as I said,
there are a lot of
researchers using it.
So there's a lot going on.
One of the things,
Mesh TensorFlow,
it's a tool for training huge
models, meaning really huge.
Like, you can have one
model that uses a whole TPU
pod, 4 terabytes of RAM.
That's how many
parameters you can do.
It's by Noam, Youlong, Niki,
Ashish, and many people.
So what if you want to
train an image generation
models on high definition
videos or process data that's
huge even at batch size 1?
So you cannot just say, oh,
I'll do one thing on one core,
another on one core,
just split it by data.
One data example has to
go on the whole machine.
And then there needs to be a
convolution that applies to it,
or a matrix multiplication.
So how can we do
this and not drown
into writing manually,
OK, on this core,
do this, and then slice back?
So the idea is build every
tensor, every dimension
it has needs to be named.
For example, you name the
first dimension is batch.
The second is length.
And the third is just
the hidden vector.
And for every dimension,
you specify how it
will be laid out on a device.
So you say, OK, batches--
for example, modern
devices, they have 2D--
they're like a 2D mesh of chips.
So the communication is
fast to nearby chips,
but not so fast across.
So you can say if it's a grid of
chips in hardware, you can say,
OK, the batch dimension will
be on the horizontal chips
and the length will be
on the vertical ones.
So we define how to split the
tensor on the hardware mesh.
And then the
operations are already
optimized to use the
processing of the hardware
to do fast communication
and operate on these tensors
as if they were single sensors.
So you specify the
dimensions by name.
You specify their layout.
And then you write your model
as if it was a single GPU model.
And so everything stays simple
except for this layout thing,
which you need to think
a little bit about.
We did a transformer on it.
We did an image transformer.
We can train models with 5
million parameters on TPU pods
with over 50% utilization.
So this paper, it's
also a to do paper,
it should be coming
out in a few weeks.
Not yet there, but it's new
state-of-the-art on translation
language modeling.
It's the next step in
really good models.
It also generates nice images.
So big models are good.
They give great results.
And this is a way of
writing them simply.
So yeah, that's the
Mesh TensorFlow.
And we try to make it--
so it runs on TPU pods,
but it also runs on
clusters of GPUs,
because we tried to not make the
mistake again to do something
that just runs on one hardware.
And with the
Tensor2Tensor library,
you're welcome to be part of it.
Give it a try.
Use it.
We are on GitHub.
There is a GitHub chat.
There is an active lobby for
Tensor2Tensor, where we also
try to be everyday day to help.
And yep, that's it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]